-Hi, everyone.
I'm Sarah Jenks-Daly,
supervising producer
at "Late Night,"
and this is "Late Night Lit."
♪♪
Few improv groups have fostered
as much talent
as that of Boom Chicago,
which has been
entertaining audiences abroad
for more than three decades.
On this episode
of "Late Night Lit,"
we're joined by Andrew Moskos
and Pep Rosenfeld,
the co-founders of Boom Chicago,
who have written a new book
about their experiences,
entitled "Boom Chicago Presents
the 30 Most Important Years
in Dutch History."
It also contains a foreword
written by our very own
Seth Meyers.
We're joined today
by all three
to discuss
the improv group's origins,
how Seth found his way
to Amsterdam,
and some of the stories
that didn't make the book.
Now, here's my conversation
with Andrew, Pep, and Seth.
Hi, everyone. I am so happy
to be joined today
by three special guests.
First up, two authors of a new
book entitled "Boom Chicago
Presents the 30 Most Important
Years in Dutch History."
First, we have Andrew Moskos.
-Hello.
-And Pep Rosenfeld.
-Hi.
It's great to be here.
Thanks.
-And a man our listeners
might be vaguely familiar with,
Seth Meyers,
who wrote the foreword
for this very entertaining
oral history,
which will be published in July.
Welcome back, Seth.
-Ooh, "vaguely."
Don't mind if I do.
[ Laughter ]
-I wanted to ask first,
Pep and Andrew,
how many notes did you give Seth
on the first draft
of his foreword?
-I think the deal was "he will
write it, but no notes."
And that was a fair deal.
-I think it also -- I would have
happily let them make --
They could have changed
whatever they wanted
and I would not have
probably noticed.
-'Cause you're not
gonna read it?
-I'm not gonna read
my own foreword.
-The book covers 30 years
of the history of Boom Chicago,
which you guys co-founded
in Amsterdam in the early '90s.
I want to talk about the book
and what it was like
to relive all these stories.
But first,
putting the book together.
Whose idea was this?
Was it more joyful
than you anticipated?
More arduous?
What was the process like?
-It was kind of joyful,
I would say.
-It was both joyful and arduous,
but I would say
it's definitely more joyful.
-Yeah.
So, we had a friend of ours
from high school,
Matt Diehl,
who's also an author,
and he has been pushing us
for years to write a book.
So, it's certainly his idea,
but the process of writing it
was a lot of fun.
I mean, we are writers
ourselves, so it's --
writing a book
was just a small step.
-And it's funny 'cause Matt did
most of the interviews
'cause a big part of the book
is sort of an oral history
of Boom Chicago,
you know, told in the words
of a lot of alumni,
including Seth,
and Matt did those interviews.
But then it was
such a delight for us
to read the interviews
afterwards
and hear what people said
about their Boom experience.
It was great.
-Seth is one of the many
people you interviewed.
When you asked people
to participate,
did you ask them
or did Matt ask them
to talk about
certain subjects?
Like, how did that...?
And Seth, you can chime in, too.
How did that
interview process go
from all of your perspectives?
-I'm not gonna lie, I'm curious
what Seth's point of view was,
how it went down for him.
-Yeah, well, so Matt,
who I've been lucky enough
to know for a long time...
And I should clarify
for our listeners.
So, Boom Chicago is a place
I went right after college,
and I spent two years
in Amsterdam
working at this
improv comedy theater.
It really was the beginning
of everything for me
and an incredibly essential
part of my growth.
And I got to meet
all these amazing people,
including Pep and Andrew.
And so, Matt reached out
and said,
"These guys are gonna
want to make this book
for the 25-year anniversary."
And I will say Matt was lovely
when he asked specific things --
"Do you remember this?
Do you remember that?"
It was so fun to talk
about them.
He did have a few too many,
"I feel"...
"My thesis is Boom Chicago
changed not just comedy,
but drama for the world."
And I would say,
"Alright, Matt."
It was a very...
It had a lot of influence.
But, you know, let's be a little
careful how we frame it all.
-Right, I was worried
he was gonna be like,
"Would you say, Seth,
that without Boom Chicago,
you wouldn't be funny at all?"
Like, no, don't ask him that.
He's a very funny fella.
-I think that the really
impressive thing,
and what I think
I would hope
readers would take away
from this book
is how it was a really
small organization
that was filled with people
who went on to do big things.
It didn't have the
infrastructure of a Second City
and it didn't have the sort
of cultural significance
of, say, an "SNL."
It was really a small theater
in Amsterdam.
And, you know,
over the course of 30 years,
a lot of people have left
and done things
that, you know,
I would say at this point,
the whole world knows.
Not that
"Late Night With Seth Meyers"
has much of
an international footprint,
but certainly, you know,
the films of Jordan Peele
or a show like "Ted Lasso"
certainly do.
-You do have a bit of appeal.
You're sort of an Amsterdam
adjunct celebrity
because you have
a passion for Amsterdam,
so your stuff gets covered here
in the Dutch press, actually.
-It's very nice when I get
a tiny side clipping
from one of
the Dutch newspapers.
-The clippings are big.
The newspaper itself is tiny.
-That's true.
-Yeah, I was just gonna say,
I think also, in contrast
with other theaters,
because Pep and I have been
so active from the beginning,
and Saskia, our third partner,
we have our...
you know, we're close
to the actors.
We were in the show ourselves
five days a week
for a long time.
So, we don't just have
sort of like a,
"Oh, we own the theater
and they're the actors"
relationship --
we've been in the trenches.
And I think that's why we have
such good friendships
with a lot of our actors
as well, too,
because there's no other theater
where the creative team
is the owners and the creative
team themselves are onstage.
-Well, the thing that
I'll say about that --
it is a total parallel
to people who say,
"Who would take over
for Lorne when he leaves 'SNL'?"
And I do think people forget
that sometimes
these institutions survive
because there is someone
who runs them
that has the underlying taste
that has been the thread
that has made it
a consistent place
for, in your case, 30 years,
in Lorne's case, 50 years.
But, you know, obviously,
there are gonna be levels
where the show
is maybe better than it was,
and then it just goes --
there's peaks and valleys.
But I think if you don't have
one person who runs it,
then it's -- you know,
it stops being unique.
-Well, I think that
comes through in the book,
certainly as a reader of it,
and not knowing
any of the history.
But I'd love to start with
or get on with the idea
for Boom Chicago, which came
from the two of you guys,
young men traveling
through Europe after graduation,
slightly maybe influenced
by some substances.
Can you kind of set
the scene for people
as to just how
this all transpired?
-Yeah, well, we always
loved Amsterdam.
We were traveling,
doing a European tour.
And when we came
to Amsterdam,
we fell in love with the city
and we wanted to move there.
And no, it's not
for the reason you think.
It was for the drugs.
And we actually were high
in a coffee shop
and had the best
stoner idea ever,
which was quit our jobs,
move to Amsterdam,
and start an English-language
comedy show.
And it worked.
-Yeah.
I just want to say
that I think the key was
that we had a pen with us
and wrote down the idea.
So like, to any young people out
there considering doing drugs,
I would just say,
yeah, do the drugs,
but just make sure
you write your ideas down.
Because half of them
will be terrible,
one quarter will be illegible,
but one quarter might just
be something.
-In Dutch --
We've got these coasters
in Holland --
like, they're thick.
It's not like cocktail napkins
that goes under a drink.
So, it's great
for writing down ideas.
-The amount of times
in the two years I was there
that Andrew said,
"I have a great idea"
and it was on the back
of one of these, like...
I guess like cork-y, almost.
They feel like
a Heineken cork coaster
that he would turn over,
and I'm like, "You know,
it doesn't actually sell
as a great idea
when you're flipping
over a beer coaster.
I clearly know
where you got this idea."
I should also say I do...
'Cause I feel like
when people hear, like,
"We quit our jobs"...
Like, they were barely jobs.
[ Laughter ]
-Seth, I was an early childhood
literacy specialist
at a corporate nonprofit.
-Seth, I was an early evening
Italian food waiter.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, when you guys sobered up
and approached the Dutch
government about this --
you talk about this story
in the book --
and the tourism board, they were
not exactly supportive,
I think is an appropriate word.
-What's the opposite
of supportive?
-So, yeah, we wrote them
and they...
We said, "Hey, here's our idea.
We want to open up
a comedy show.
We want it to be good enough
that it gets reviewed
in the arts pages
of newspapers."
Newspapers were a thing
that used to come out every day.
-But you still have them, right?
There's still a robust
newspaper scene,
still robust newspapers
in Holland, right?
-Yeah, actually,
they are still robust.
Ten daily newspapers still,
and so it's a literate place.
They get thinner.
They got thinner over the years.
But, so we wrote the city
and the tourism office
and said, "Here's our idea.
What do you think?"
And they they wrote us back
quickly, by fax,
because it was 1993.
And the fax said,
"Your idea will not work,"
which is a pretty pessimistic
start for a tourism office.
-But they went further.
They fleshed it out.
-Oh, they fleshed it out.
"The Dutch do not want
to see a show in English.
The tourists do not want
to see a show at all.
You will need subsidy
to theater in the Netherlands.
You will not get any subsidy.
So, think twice
about your plans."
So, well, they were right about
we never got subsidy.
-To be fair, I think....
Does it count as subsidies,
the help we got during COVID?
'Cause then that would be
the final domino of that letter
falling over.
-But, no, we came.
It worked.
We framed the fax, and it's up
in our bar right now.
And 30 years later,
still having fun.
-And the woman who wrote the fax
to us has come to the show
and had a great time,
and we bought her a drink
and showed her her own letter
up on the wall.
And I like to think that was
a moving moment for her.
-It was a moving moment for us.
I really wanted to see
what she said,
and it was nice
that she liked it.
-That's amazing.
I love that.
Seth, you spoke about
how much influence
this had on your career.
Can you talk about,
namely, how you heard of it?
Like, how did it come
across your radar
when you were graduating
from school?
-Yeah, so, it was
real early days of the theater.
I think it had only been 2 or 3
seasons that you guys had done,
and it wasn't year-round
when I started.
But my dear college friend
and close friend today,
a former "Late Night" writer,
Peter Grosz,
he basically saw
an audition notice for it.
He had talked to somebody
who'd done it.
He was far more adventuresome
in spirit than I was
and thought we should
go audition for it.
And the other thing
I should note is that
Pep and Andrew
both went to Northwestern,
which is where Pete and I went.
Pep was in Mee-Ow,
which was the improv troupe at
Northwestern that I was also in.
So, in a weird way, it was
a tailor-made audition
for Pete and my skill set,
because you could tell,
"Oh, the person
who's putting this together
has done Mee-Ow,
and we've done Mee-Ow."
And so it was a course of three
days of auditioning for it,
and it never...
In the back of my head,
it just never occurred to me
that we might get the job,
until we got the job.
And then it was very funny
because Pete was the one
who thought it was a good idea,
and then immediately
he was like,
"I got this girlfriend and I
don't know if it's a good idea."
And I was all
guns blazing to go.
In the end,
Pete went as well.
But I didn't have
a passport at the time.
I'd never left the country,
and so it was a giant
leap of faith
that was really,
I mean, incredible.
It was incredibly rewarding.
When I look back
at the bigger swings
I've taken in my life,
that one certainly counts.
-Seth and Pete both had
a great audition.
I remember they did a big --
they did a scene in the audition
involving an enormous
cheese wheel, right?
And they were rolling
a big cheese wheel.
That, I do remember
from your audition.
-I remember a big cowboy song
that Seth sang.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Do you remember that, Seth?
-I don't have
any memory of that.
I know that I've been told
in the years since
to stop it
with my cowboy songs.
[ As Lorne Michaels ]
"You know, I don't see you
as 'the cowboy song guy.'"
I'm not gonna say
who said it.
I'm not gonna
say who said it.
-And then, Seth,
you quit your job, too.
It was kind of similar to mine,
if I remember correctly.
-Yeah, I said...
I think what it was in the end
was they said, "You don't
actually have to quit.
You just tell us you can't make
your next year's worth
of shifts."
At the Twisted Lizard.
And I will say,
when I left Boom Chicago,
I came back and started working
at the Twisted Lizard again.
And that was what I like to call
the worst time of my life.
[ Laughter ]
-In the book, the majority
of the alumni talk so lovingly
about the Dutch national
football club
and how many Boom alums
became diehard fans,
including Brendan Hunt
and Jason Sudeikis, obviously,
who created
and starred in "Ted Lasso."
Can you guys talk about how that
took over in terms of the fandom
and how you all became
such devoted supporters?
-This is really Saskia,
who's not here,
which is Andrew's wife
and sort of the third leg
of the tripod that keeps
Boom Chicago up and running.
But she is Dutch
and she loves football.
And the first World Cup
I was there for
was the 1998 World Cup.
And the Dutch team
was very good,
made it to the semifinals,
and it was quite dramatic.
And you just watch the whole
city sort of turn orange
and everybody's in a really
good mood all the time.
And, uh, I love Dutch people,
but they're not in a really
good mood all the time.
So, when that happens,
it's hard not to think like,
"Ah, this is a wave
I want to ride."
And it was just really fun.
And mostly,
I think at that time, I mean,
obviously it's different now,
but almost all of us were
American sports fans who had not
fallen in love with soccer yet.
And so that was kind
of our introduction
to how wonderful it was.
-Yeah, our theater
at the time, too,
was on the Leidseplein,
which is a big square
where a lot of people go
to watch these games.
And when Ajax or when
the Dutch national team wins,
there's a balcony in front
of the big theater there,
and they raise the trophy
on the -- in front
of thousands of fans.
So, it was not only
a great season for football
and a great set of years,
it was also the place
where football was celebrated --
football meaning soccer.
And that was an extra piece
that the celebrations
were sort of
part of the Boom Chicago
experience as well.
-I would add just two things.
One is Seth with you saying,
like, the whole city
is in a good mood,
I would say yes,
until the inevitable moment
that the Dutch team collapses,
and then it just --
it's so crushing.
It's so miserable.
It's the worst.
-Yeah.
-And we've seen it live
once on...
-Well, not live, but we've
seen it on Seth's show,
which is still one of my
favorite moments from the show,
except that it involved
a Dutch team losing.
-I rewatched it very recently,
and it was very painful
and real.
-Yeah, it was.
-It was.
-It was drama on your show.
-Was that when
you threw the iPad?
-Yeah.
Okay, I remember that too. Yeah.
-I'm very good
at not responding to people.
I feel like a robust, happy life
is one that never responds
to people on social media.
But a few people, I remember,
after that --
because I posted that video
on Twitter, they're like,
"Must be nice to be able
to break an iPad."
And what I wanted to say is,
"[Bleep] you!"
-I'm not a sports fan
really at all, or I never was,
and then I did the same thing
that you did, Seth,
which was a show
with Brendan Hunt.
But yours was only part
about football,
but mine was totally about
the World Cup one year.
And the bit was Brendan
knows everything
about soccer, because he does,
and I knew nothing about
anything, because I didn't.
And we did this show
during the World Cup,
and we would then show
the games after the show.
I mean, the show was a flop,
because it turns out
that if you're a football fan,
you don't really want to watch
a comedy show,
and if you're a comedy show,
you don't want to watch
the football.
But I just learned a little bit
every day from Brendan
from watching the games, and now
I can't miss a national game.
-I should say,
a really funny thing,
I think is very funny is that
these guys wanted to write --
This book was originally written
at the 25th anniversary
and I think they thought,
"Oh, that's when you
write the book."
Because at this point, like,
it's not -- everything
great people have done,
like, I feel like
they've done it.
And then like,
the minute the book came out,
"Ted Lasso" came out
and they were like, "[Bleep]."
-Five years too early.
So now this is --
this book is, and again,
it's not
just Brendan and Jason.
It's also Joe Kelly
who was out at Boom Chicago.
And I should note, I think that
I should say, Jon and Andrew
were going to be guests on
the show in a couple of weeks,
and due to the fact
that we're not doing shows
because of the writer's strike,
they will not be on.
But I think you guys would have
been the, if you count me,
you would have been the
11th and 12th Boom alum
who has appeared on the show.
-Wow.
-So can you name...
I'm going to give you me.
Can you name the other nine?
-Oh, gosh.
-Are we counting, Pete?
-Yes. Pete counts.
Now you need eight.
-Amber.
-Seven.
-Tarik.
-Yeah, he's been
on the show. He did bits.
-I forgot about Tarik.
I thought he was only Amber.
So I'm going to give you --
You still have seven.
-Okay, Jordan, of course.
-Yep. Six.
-Ike, Kay, Brendan, Matt Jones.
-Five, four, three.
-The other two are --
one is obvious.
-Yeah, one is obvious
that you're missing.
-Josh.
-Josh, yep.
And one more.
I'm going to give it to you.
Joe Kelly was on.
-Joe Kelly. Yeah.
-Also Carice was on.
-She's not technically
Boom Chicago though.
-Oh, okay.
-She was just one of these
really, you know,
the hanger-on type.
We had a lot of Dutch celebs
who just wanted to be
around the Boom Chicago heat.
-It's so funny, she's become
perhaps the leading female actor
in the Netherlands.
And when we kind of say,
"Oh, yeah, she used to date Josh
and hung out a lot
and, you know, would get high
on the couches with us,"
people are like,
"What, Carice van Houten?"
Yeah, we've known her that long.
-Yeah, Carice van Houten
of "Game of Thrones."
-Melisandre in
"Game of Thrones."
-Yes.
-I went to Burger King
once with her and Josh,
and we were super high.
I'm not sure if this
is a good story to tell.
And we started
doing bits with each other
and our thing became,
"Oh, we don't understand
each other when we do bits."
And that was our relationship
for a long time.
-One of my favorite things,
she says in the book
is how she had, like,
Dutch people don't date
the way Americans date.
And so Josh was sort of
her first boyfriend
in the American sense,
hand-holding, flowers.
And then one night
they both got high
and were watching
some documentary
about a American serial killer.
And she was so stoned
she thought,
"Oh, no, it's Josh,"
because it was all...
it was all one
of those like, "Dateline", like,
"It was the love
that was too good to be true."
She was like, "Oh my God, this
guy did everything Josh did,
flowers, hand-holding.
It's all the classic signs."
[ Laughter ]
-I think that's a good segue
to ask Andrew and Pep,
this community of actors
and performers
who developed this love
for Dutch culture,
including the Dutch
national team, too,
but what do you think
are the most common things
that maybe stay
with Boom Chicago alumni,
in terms of the connection to
Amsterdam or love for country?
What do you hear most
from people that they miss
or that they want to
come back to?
-Hmm.
I mean,
it might be the Efteling.
-The Efteling is a great
amusement park
in the Netherlands.
It's kind of the Dollywood
of the Netherlands,
which is, it's super credible
and a world-class park
that's a little bit smaller.
It's in nature and it's --
it's a little bit
more regional-feeling.
But everyone loves the Efteling.
-I didn't realize,
though, I read --
and you will know
if this is true or not, Andrew,
the second most-attended
European amusement park
to a Disneyland Paris?
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Euro Disney, right?
So it's small,
but it's real deal.
-Oh, yeah. I'm sorry.
It's only small compared
to Disney World,
but it's certainly
the real deal.
-To me, the thing about
the Efteling,
and it's such a Dutch thing
about it,
is that whereas most
American amusement parks,
they sort of tear down
everything
and then build the park,
here, there was this forest,
and they left the forest
and sort of build around it,
and it's just this gorgeous,
yeah, park with awesome rides
in there as well.
-I think alumni
also miss bike riding,
because that is really
a part of Amsterdam is,
you just bike everywhere
and it's just your way
you get around.
I think that's nice.
Even though the weather
isn't always great,
there's certainly a cafe,
terrace outdoor culture,
which is nice.
And when the weather is good,
everyone just enjoys it.
-When the weather's good,
somehow nobody's employed
and everybody is sitting
on a terrace drinking rosé.
It's really weird. I don't know
what their jobs are.
I know what mine is,
and it allows me to drink rosé
at 2 p.m. on a Tuesday,
but I don't know about
everybody else. It's weird.
-It does, I felt like, the city
always expanded to your mood
and the weather,
and if you were having
a good time,
like, that city stays open late
in a way that is
not aggressive or grimy.
You can just have --
I mean, I feel like I've never
had more 20-hour sort of,
you know, party days
where you just,
the day starts and then
the next thing you know,
it's 5:00 in the morning.
And, you know,
especially in the summer
when it's already
getting light again.
I remember one of the first,
and to this day,
maybe the coolest thing
Pep ever did.
We were on a boat ride,
and remember, there was a place,
a bakery you could
pull the boat up next to
and get like,
the first croissants of the day?
And it was really
just amazing.
I remember that
was like, Pete and I,
our introduction to Amsterdam
was let's go on
a midnight or whatever,
probably 3:00 a.m. boat ride,
and the next thing we know,
we're pulling up,
like, the window onto the canal
and somebody just
hands out a bag.
-He'd sneak out
with his undershirt on.
-Yeah, it was certainly
the most like a drug deal
I've ever seen
purchasing croissants.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you guys look along
the way at any point,
maybe when you look up
at that fax
from that Dutch woman
in the government,
did you ever think this result
was possible 30 years later?
To have this be your life,
that you've created this thing
that is obviously
such a success?
-What I always say is,
I think I did not.
I thought, "Wow, this is
going to be a fantastic
summer project in 1993."
And I think, deep down,
Andrew thought the opposite.
-Yeah, I thought
it was going to work.
Yeah,
I thought it was going to work.
What I did not predict is that
I would be middle-aged one day.
That was inconceivable.
-I will say that I studied
abroad in college
and the thing to do
was go to Amsterdam
and obviously eat space cakes,
but go see Boom Chicago.
And that was in the earlier,
maybe, like,
right after Seth left.
But like, early days of 2000,
and my friends were all doing
that when they went
to Amsterdam.
That's pretty fantastic.
-We like your friends.
-I wanted to ask you guys,
all three of you,
many of the stories in the book,
there's so many funny anecdotes.
Some include drugs
and some capacity,
and I'm sure there are some
that maybe were inappropriate
for the book on some level.
But was there anything that you
really wished made the cut
that you either couldn't keep in
for specific reasons
or just didn't have
the space to have in there?
-The editor's cut.
-[ Laughs ]
-There was a whole chapter
written in The Voice of Germany,
and it was hilarious
and it was cut.
It was an awesome chapter.
That was my darling
that was cut.
Seth, I'm going to send you
a copy of the Germany chapter.
-I don't know
if it's in the book,
but we were talking
about the Efteling,
and this was one of my favorite
"Shame on Ike" stories,
of which there are legion.
But somebody brought a football,
like, an American football,
which is already just
a terrifying shape
to Dutch people.
And we were at Efteling,
and we're kind of
throwing the football
back and forth.
And one of my favorite
things about Ike
is he looks athletic
and he's not.
And so he went
to throw the ball to somebody,
and he threw the worst pass
I've ever seen.
It went flying, and it was
going towards an old woman
in a wheelchair who was just...
And two things happened.
Ike threw it,
saw what was going to happen,
turned his head
and just walked away
like he hadn't
even been playing football.
Like, he immediately was
building his own alibi.
And my brother, God love him,
who is the most important thing
that ever happened to Ike
is that he met
someone like my brother.
Josh just went in
a dead sprint and dove
and just tapped the ball away.
Didn't catch it,
but just, like,
tapped it away from hitting this
Dutch woman right in the face.
And then the whole bus
ride home, I was like,
"You just walked away."
He was like, "See,
I don't wanna -- I -- Look.
We could talk about this
as much as you want.
That's not how I saw it."
[ Laughter ]
-"'Cause I couldn't see it at
all because I was walking away
and not looking."
-Yeah, "I don't know.
-"Does everybody see
where their ball goes?"
[ Laughter ]
-So in addition to the book
coming out in July,
you guys are coming to the US.
You have a couple of events.
Can you tell us about those
and where people can find you?
-Yes, absolutely.
We've got three big stops
with nice events.
They're not just book readings.
They're things with performances
and a lot of alumni as well.
We start in New York,
June 21st at Le Poisson Rouge.
Seth is going to host it,
Amber Ruffin, Tarik Davis,
Holly Walker, other alumni
who are based in New York.
Then the next day, Chicago
on the 22nd of June at iO.
Pep and I are going
to be guests,
monologuists telling stories
at the Armando Diaz.
And then in Los Angeles
on the 29th
at Gold-Diggers
in East Hollywood,
Ike Barinholtz will
be hosting Colton Dunn, others.
Brendan Hunt
will be performing.
-That's going to be
a crazy show, too.
-Yeah.
In his band character,
Elvis Prestello.
That has not happened in years,
so that's a big event
at Gold-Diggers on the 29th.
Hope we see people there.
-Yeah, it'll be great.
-Well, congratulations
on this book, you guys.
It was so much fun to read,
and it will be published
in early July,
but it is available
for preorder now.
So everyone go do that.
And Seth, Pep, Andrew,
thanks so much for your time.
-Thank you.
-Thanks a lot.
-Thanks, Jenks.
♪♪
-This has been "Late Night Lit."
My thanks to Seth Meyers,
Mike Shoemaker, Andrew Moskos,
Pep Rosenfeld, Jay Johnson,
Ross Luippold,
and Rafaela Huellas.
Our theme music was written
and performed by the 8G Band.
For "Late Night
with Seth Meyers,"
I'm Sarah Jenks-Daly.
Thank you for listening,
and happy reading.
♪♪